oui
[Musique]
je suis heureuse d'avoir avec nous le
professeur eliane warner ancien
directeur général de l'agencé spatiale
européenne
commençons par cette journée d'avril
1961 qui a tout changé
le vol de youri gagarine le premier
homme dans l'espace
et vous étiez petit garçon à l'époque
avez vous des souvenirs de ce jour là
quand j'ai entendu parler du lancement
de youri gagarine et de son vol autour
de notre terre je me suis dit que
c'était incroyable ça ou vous l'avenir
au rêve à tous pour un petit garçon
j'avais 7 ans à l'époque
c'est en effet une très forte motivation
pour comprendre qu'on peut avoir un rêve
et qu'on peut réaliser les rêves sont
sans limites
il n'y a pas de limitation donc j'ai été
vraiment fasciné et inspiré par youri
gagarine plus tard quand j'ai visité la
cité des étoiles
quand j'ai vu cet endroit quand j'ai
visité baïkonour
et vu la maison où il a vécu avant le
lancement j'ai de nouveau ressenti
toutes ces émotions
je regrette de ne pas l'avoir rencontré
en personne
voilà ce que je peux dire c'était un
vrai héros de son époque beaucoup de
qualités de youri gagarine chez les
cosmonautes et les astronautes
d'aujourd'hui les qualités et
compétences que youri possédait était
bien sûr différentes de celles des
cosmonautes et astronautes aujourd'hui
parce que son objectif principal
ce n'était pas de procéder à des
expériences technique ou médicale
son objectif principal était d'aller
là-haut et de revenir à la maison tous
sains et saufs
c'était un pilote sur gt sa principale
compétence aujourd'hui par exemple quand
nous recherchons des astronautes
européens
nous prenons aussi des pilotes mais ce
n'est plus la première et la plus
importante des compétences nous
embauchons des gens capables de faire
des expériences scientifiques
les expériences technologiques etc donc
c'était un type différentes compétences
ailleurs été la même
dans le cas du premier astronaute
américain c'était une époque différente
il ne fallait qu entrer dans l'espace il
fallait posséder toute compétence que
quand on utilise l'espace à quel point
pensez vous que le sourire de youri
gagarine a été important il est célèbre
pour son sourire oui le sourire de youri
gagarine nous montrent qu'il était très
heureux de faire ce qu'ils faisaient
son sourire et le sourire d'une grande
personnalité
je les ai vus plusieurs fois il a fait
un vol vraiment très spécial en revenant
sur terre il a dû sortir de la capsule
et descendre en parachute
c'était quelque chose de très difficile
mais il souriait l'air de dire vous
voyez je les fais c'est ce sourire que
je vois sur son visage j'ai eu la chance
d'assister au lancement d'une fusée il
ya quelques années j'ai rencontré les
familles des cosmonautes et astronautes
avant leur départ pour la fusée je
trouve que c'est un moment plein
d'émotion je me suis demandé ce que
ressent que ces familles
je pensais au courage de ses cosmonautes
et astronautes karsenti youri gagarine
selon vous avant ce vol dans l'espace
je peux imaginer qu'il a dû avoir des
sentiments ambivalents
d'abord le fait d'être le premier c'est
bien sûr un honneur c'est un grand
honneur et une chance mais en même temps
c'est très risqué quand j'emmène les
astronautes européens baïkonour pour un
lancement
j'ai toujours peur pour eux parce que
j'aurais pu être leur père c'est
toujours faire de leur dire au revoir à
dieu je crois qu'à l'époque il
s'agissait des sentiments encore plus
forte pour sa famille et pour lui-même
entré dans une fusée cela veut dire
rentrer dans une structure qui a un
système d' explosion contrôlée
c'est ce qui fait voler la fusée je peux
donc imaginer qu'il avait des sentiments
ambivalents
mais c'était une personnalité forte qui
a dit d'accord je vais le faire cela
vous touche toujours aujourd'hui quand
vous voyez le lancement des fusées
chaque fois que j'ai visité un site de
lancement
je les fais plusieurs fois aux états
unis à baïkonour j'ai toujours été très
touchée oui youri gagarine a dû
ressentir une pression immense jour là
pensez vous que c'est la même chose pour
les cosmonautes et astronautes que
d'aujourd'hui où sont-ils est beaucoup
plus sûr de ce qu'il faut je pense que
c'est toujours la même chose pour les
astronautes d'aujourd'hui ils ont un peu
peur quand ils sont dans la capsule
mais ils savent qu'ils sont de service
et ils sont très professionnels chaque
fois je leur parle après c'est leur
demande s'ils ont peur ils répondent non
nous avions seulement confiance en ce
que nous devions faire pour le succès du
lancement sur l'ordre je suppose que du
riz gagarine pensait de la même manière
mais je suis sûr qu'ils ont tous
conscience des risques qu'ils prennent
durant votre carrière vous avez
travaillé avec beaucoup d'astronautes ai
vu beaucoup de lancements
vous vous dites que vous rêvez toujours
d'être cosmonautes aux astronautes
qu'est ce qui est nécessaire pour être
astronaute il y a bien sûr beaucoup
d'exigence à commencer par la santé les
aspects psychologiques et cetera
selon moi c'est un astronaute doit
réunir trois qualités à la fois
en premier lieu il ou elle doit savoir
travailler en équipe dans bateau ensuite
il ou elle
il doit être prêt à suivre le
commandement enfin il ou elle doit être
prêt à commander car pendant votre
séjour à bord d'un vaisseau spatial
vous aurez à jouer ces trois rôles être
membre de l'équipe suivre et à teaser
ping lille peut trouver ces trois
capacités dans un seul cerveau n'est pas
si fréquent sur terre je sais que
l'agencé spatiale européenne souhaite
désormais prendre le chemin de la
diversité non seulement cherche-t-elle à
attirer plus de femmes qui rêverait de
devenir astronaute
mais elle invite aussi les personnes
handicapées à s'entraîner pour devenir
astronaute
selon vous comment cela va-t-il changer
la manière dont on perçoit les
astronomes ils sont généralement
considéré comme les personnes les plus
habiles de la planète est en excellente
santé
revenons à la naissance de l'aviation
seules les personnes en excellente santé
pouvait piloter les aéronefs
aujourd'hui n'importe quelle personne
peut les piloter c'est le moment
d'ouvrir l'espace aux personnes
handicapées de cette année nous avons
fait des tests il ya quatre ans nous
avons fait des tests de vols
paraboliques avec la participation de
gens handicapés
ça a été une grande expérience pour eux
et une grande expérience pour moi cela
m'a beaucoup touché
y at il quelque chose dans l'industrie
aérospatiale qui auraient besoin d'un
petit bouleversement d'un changement
ce que nous devons faire c'est évident
c'est que nous devons comprendre que les
activités spatiales et devienne une
marchandise c'est toujours fascinant et
inspirant toujours motivant mais c'est
une marchandise
cela veut dire que la prochaine étape
est la commercialisation et je suis
certain qu'il va y avoir des activités
touristiques
mais la première chose à faire est de
rendre l'industrie plus commerciale dans
tous les domaines l'industrie est tout
le temps l'objet d'évolutions très
rapide
qu'est-ce qui vous excite le plus dans
l'industrie à l'heure actuelle ce que
nous voyons en ce moment c'est une
réelle transformation numérique
c'est seulement dans l'industrie mais
aussi dans le cadre de l' agence il ya
aussi cette notion de nouvel espace le
nouvel espace tel que nous l'entendons
consistant les activités de petites
entreprises à y construire des fusées
dans leur salon je suis allé à la
rencontre de toutes ces petites
entreprises et le résultat est assez
clair le nouvel espace ce n'est pas
l'activité des petites entreprises
le nouvel espace c'est la
commercialisation réduction des cris ni
les innovations l'agilité et la
souplesse
je crois que c'est le plus grand défi
auquel toutes les institutions doivent
faire face de nos jours que ce soit les
entités publiques les agences les
entités de recherche mais aussi des
industries cela peut être réalisé
beaucoup plus vite dans le cadre d'une
transformation numérique que sans
transformation numérique
pour moi la transformation numérique et
ses nouvelles activités spatiales
arrivent ensemble et ça va être un bon
pas en avant pour l'espace
yann horner vous venez de quitter vos
fonctions le 1er mars
yann que ressentez-vous par rapport à
cela bien sûr que je suis triste mais en
même temps je suis très reconnaissante
d'avoir pu faire ce travail pendant plus
de cinq ans
pourriez-vous ont partagé quelques 100
avec nous c'est très dangereux parce que
comme je l'aï toujours dit j'étais
directeur général pas directeur spéciale
donc si je choisis un moment précis ce
ne serait pas correct mais je voudrais
évoquer mars
surtout parce que ça se passe en
coopération avec la russie
exo marques et le lancement réussi avec
trace casse orbiteur en 2016 ça a été un
succès sans aucun doute l'un des moments
forts de cette période est aussi les
vols d'astronautes depuis baïkonour
sous votre direction y at-il lieu de
défis que l' agence spatiale européenne
n'a pas relevé et que vous regrettez je
ne vais pas évoquer toutes mes erreurs
et les défis auxquels je n'ai pas su
répondre mais je me suis vraiment battu
très fort pour l'espace unis européens
et avec des partenaires internationaux
dans le cas des partenaires
internationaux cela a très bien marché
alors que l'espace union européen est
une question compliquée parce que comme
vous le savez il y à l'union européenne
et l'agencé spatiale européenne
deux entités différentes que je n'ai pas
réussi à vraiment réunir c'est
probablement le plus grand problème que
j'ai regardé en arrière
vous n'avez pas réussi à y parvenir
pendant votre carrière
oui y avez vous réfléchi plus
profondément que faudrait il faire
oui mes erreurs ont probablement été dû
au fait que je n'ai pas toujours été
suffisamment diplomate
j'ai tendance à toujours dire la vérité
je dis les choses honnêtement de manière
très directe
certaines personnes n'apprécient pas
cela
parfois il est plus intelligent d'être
prudent avec ces mots que de toujours
dire la vérité mais je suis warner je ne
peux pas faire autrement
j'ai fait ça ma manière c'est ainsi
on a récemment vu l'essor des start-up
dans le domaine spatial
je voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez
des ambitions dans l'espace d'elon musk
est de jeff bezos
pourquoi sont ils tellement intéressé
par l'espace selon vous certains
qualifient cela de sport de choix des
milliardaires mais les cas des lots ne
me gênait de jeff bezos sont bien
différents jeff bezos est un
milliardaire
il utilise beaucoup de son argent pour
aller dans l'espace alors qu'ellen must
mais également beaucoup de son argent
qu'il a tiré de paypal mais il a surtout
de très bon contrat avec la nasa des
lanceurs bon marché ce qui est bien je
pense donc que c'est plus qu'un simple
sport elon musk est un vrai homme
d'affaires il voit les opportunités que
présente espaces voilà pourquoi cela a
tant de succès mais quand nous parlons
des start up
nous parlons aussi des start up qui
réunissent disons 10 ou 15 personnes
seulement il y en a beaucoup dans le
monde et je suis content que cela se
produise parce que ce sont des nouveaux
marchés les marchés d'avenir plus
seulement des marchés traditionnels et
je crois donc que cela va transformer le
vieillit jeu face à l'avenir dans les
discussions quant à la prochaine
direction à choisir la lune ou mars
de quel côté vous c'est très simple nous
irons sur la lune mais ce ne sera pas un
retour sur la lune
nous irons en avant sur la ville
pourquoi je dis qu'on ira en avant vers
la lune parce que ça ne sera pas comme
dans les années 60 dans le cadre d'une
course à l'espace
nous irons ensemble dans le cadre d'un
partenariat international
ainsi la lune et la prochaine
destination
elle est intéressante d'un point de vue
scientifique elle est intéressante d'un
point de vue technologique
elle est peut être un point de départ
pour aller sur mars c'est réalisable
on peut faire un aller retour sur la
lune en l'espace d'une semaine
alors que si vous voulez aller sur mars
ça prend à peu près deux ans pouvez vous
imaginer une situation comme celle qu'a
traversée apollo 13 avoir un souci
technique après deux trois jours
et attendre ensuite deux ans pour
revenir chez eux ou bien si trois mois
plus tard vous avez un problème de santé
et que vous devez attendre deux ans pour
venir
je pense que pour aller sur mars il faut
des technologies absolument différente
voilà pourquoi je ne pense pas que cela
se produise dans les prochaines
décennies
mais aller sur la lune y aller ensemble
c'est très important
j'appelle ça le village lunaire que
pensez-vous des forces spatiales des
états unis et de l'aider en général
d'une guerre dans l'espace de la
militarisation de l'espace à l' agence
spatiale européenne nous avons une
convention qui date de 1975 selon
laquelle l'âge ans existe uniquement à
des fins pacifiques et je suis du même
avis personnellement je ne devons pas
transférer nos activités de guerre on
aux activités militaires dans l'espace
je peux comprendre que l'observation de
la terre pour la sécurité c'est
également utilisé dans le domaine
militaire mais nous ne devrions pas opté
pour une guerre des étoiles quelle
qu'elle soit je suis absolument contre
nous avons parcouru un incroyablement
lent chemin l'espace de 50 ans seulement
pourriez-vous nous épater et nous dire
de quoi pourrions nous être témoin dans
les cinquante années à venir assez
gentil je serais mort dans les cinquante
années à venir ça c'est sûr qu'est ce
qui va se produire
je suis sûr que comme je l' ai déjà dit
l'espace deviendra une marchandise
nous verrons que des gens ordinaires 3d
millionnaire ou des milliardaires
pourront voyager dans l'espace
je crois que nous serons témoins de cela
dans les cinquante années à venir
nous verrons aussi le premier homme ou
femme sur la surface de mars
ça c'est ce qui concerne les vols
spatiaux habités
l'espace sera utilisé comme un bien au
quotidien c'est déjà partiellement le
cas avec la navigation par satellite les
télécommunications d'observation
terrestre mais l'espace sera vraiment un
autre continent pour nous comme la lune
est leur la plus basse nous aurons
des infrastructures de production dans
l'espace parce que la microgravité est
une excellente base pour les médicaments
les matériaux et cetera nous verrons
donc que l'espace c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il faut développer et que les
indices
les individus devraient utiliser deux
jours à tuer mon fils de 6 ans a depuis
ses 4 ans a envie de devenir cosmonaute
quels conseils lui donneriez-vous
devrait lui dire s'ils me posent des
questions sur la vie sur mars il vous
pose la question c'est déjà une bonne
chose cela veut dire qu'il est curieux
il est très important d'être curieux
donc ma première recommandation serait
reste curieux ensuite je dirais bien sûr
fait des études à l'école à l'université
et cherche ce qui t'intéresse d'un point
de vue scientifique et technologique
ensuite c'est le moment de postuler
il s'intéresse aux extraterrestres se
demande s'il ya d'autres gens qui vivent
dans l'espace sur d'autres planètes que
lui répondre yes il y attend de galaxies
et dans chaque galaxie
il y attend des toiles y attend planète
nous avons une énorme quantité de
planètes dans notre univers la
probabilité que nous soyons seul est
très très faible
mais la probabilité pour nous de
rencontrer est aussi très faibles à
cause de la distance
donc on peut dire que oui il y à des
extraterrestres mais nous ne les avons
pas encore rencontrés et nous ne les
rencontrerons peut-être jamais il sera
fou de joie et à merci beaucoup pour
cette discussion ça a été un grand
plaisir
[Musique]
je